the grandchester is back in Poland how
does it feel to be playing in the
capital city of Warsaw yeah it's very
nice to play in Poland you know I'm
getting used to it more and more which
is nice and
um yeah now I think it's even more
difficult that it was last year I mean
Magnus is praying and
and so on but um yeah very happy to be
back and also that it's that is you know
wrapping a bit on the classical it's a
good feeling to be back in Warsaw I was
not there last year but it was the last
time I was I did win a world
championship in Bridge so it definitely
feels good to come back I'm happy to to
be here I've been to Poland a few times
a beautiful city I I think now we are
located at the most Central I've ever
been located and
yeah just just you know it's really uh a
very Grand European Capital also so
clean you know yeah just a pleasure to
talk around I'm happy to be here oh it's
wonderful my mom and I definitely love
it here in war so we were here last year
and the city is just amazing and the
people is great I'm very grateful that
there's a
a tour here in Warsaw in the part of
granchester
oh it's great I think
the everything got better the the
weather
and also the the location of the hotel
it's much better we're right in the old
town it's so beautiful oh it yeah it
feels very nice to be back in in Warsaw
um I I just thought about actually
recently that you know I played in
Warsaw quite a few times but I never
played classical chess always rapid
templates yeah I used to be Europeans
represent Blitz and no the Granger store
so yeah kind of uh it feels like a
continuation of a cycle or something for
me
turkey it's a new experience for me I
don't play this format before okay I
will see for me it's uh super exciting
because I'm living just here so honestly
it's there is like nothing better than
it can be
also for myself there's like zero
pressure because nobody's
expecting me to to fight for something
bigger so I can just
enjoy the playing here and hopefully I
will make some nice surprises here I
really enjoy Warsaw because I was
staying here for a month during the last
year travels so I really enjoyed the
city I really enjoy the people and as a
Ukrainian person I can say only good
things about polish nation and just
about volunteers it's going to be very
exciting I am really excited to play
against the best place in the world and
it's very interesting to compete against
them especially when the world champion
is the next I'm playing uh rapid and
Blitz here in Warsaw for the second time
and uh
in the last couple years so the first
time was the world rapid and blitzed
Championship which didn't go so well so
I'm hoping to do but you're hoping to do
better uh this time but but it's yeah
it's nice to be here
uh feels a little bit like a summer Vibe
here already so I'm looking forward to
it
[Music]